this is us season finale of which is
Tuesday 9:00 Eastern on NBC the man who
plays Kevin Pierson in the incredibly
popular this is us Justin Hartley good
to see you sir thank you man thanks for
having me we got to get into right off
the bat how we how this came about came
about without we met I mean how we this
came together I'm on the flight right
home from the Super Bowl right you walk
on the plane with your wife right and
you you guys are not booked sitting next
to that that's and this is probably
happen to everyone right where you're
traveling with a companion whether it be
your friend or your wife and you know
when it's your wife or your girlfriend
or your husband or whatever it's a
little bit more like a problem right you
want to sit next a long flight yeah and
they had us booked you know it's a
flight from the Superbowl so it's busy
and they have us booked in separate
seats and I think what might have
happened was I always request an aisle
mm-hmm and so I think they were trying
to help me out by giving me an aisle Oh
God
what are you six - is that what you're
about six two and a half what happens
but you on behalf no no but but yeah so
like I if you have to go to the bathroom
right and it's one of those seats where
you I just don't like asking I'm out I
will hold it which you know for every
part of your manhood no and I but I feel
bad and the person sleeping and I'm like
I got to go to the bathroom you know
like a little kid so I like the aisle
that we have to worry about okay and I
established right away to the person
with the window I'm like hey listen if
you got a pee I'm your guy wake me up
you need to be a little bit more
descriptive and you're saying I'm your
guy if you gotta pee I've got to say
don't worry about it you can wake me up
uh but that's very nice of you that you
would tell your your row mate yeah if
you're concerned about mm-hmm
bothering me don't be concerned about it
I like that speaking of nice getting
back to to you so my wife and I walk on
the walk on the flight and she's like
you know we're not sitting together it's
it becomes kind of like a thing of
course it is but just for one second
because the man over here mmm stands up
and says I got no problem I'm all about
seat karma and I will I'll give up my
seat no problem don't worry about it yes
happily yes turns out it worked out did
someone else it was able to move for us
and then on the very same flight it
happens again and you offered up your
seat again it was just like I'll play
you know I'm a seat karma guy really are
but I'm also a Wi-Fi guy as well yes I
always get the Wi-Fi and I'm on the
flight home I get the Wi-Fi and then all
of a sudden my Twitter feed starts
blowing up with a tweet from Justin
Hartley explaining about how you know -
yeah by the way and then you know
tagging the show as well was very
associated this is what you have to do
but I tell you what and you don't know
this and I'm not setting you up here at
all but that's not our first flight
together ok not our first flight so
let's walk through this one so years ago
no we were we were I'm on the flight oh
and I'm going to no it's great I'm going
to New York I think you had you were
doing the up fronts mm-hmm for your new
journey right for you
oh yeah fur fur for the Great Escape my
one and done show you couldn't have been
nicer you were like I mean because I was
like oh man this is so cool and I like
wanted to text my friends and stuff I
couldn't believe us sitting next to you
and then I was like no be cool don't
like bother him this was years ago and I
was also going to the up fronts for some
failed things like the the window so we
were perfectly would like the nicest guy
so funny so I tweeted you back and then
you tweeted me back I thought to myself
this is the most 21st century thing of
all time that I'm communicating with
somebody you lost rows behind me I have
38,000 that's right that's right so I
just came back and we we shook hands and
I'm got to come on and now here we are
Justin Hartley if this is us here in the
Rich Eisen show what what year was the
2012 six years ago is that all Wow okay
yeah whether you say there's at all I'm
like man that's a long time so you have
been everywhere sir at that Super Bowl
let's let's talk about that
just because you being a lead-pipe
wielding professional and promoting your
show sure and it was an NBC Super Bowl
right you were on Fallon after the Super
Bowl right which was a live show they
were doing from Minneapolis so that
required you yeah to leave the Super
Bowl early when did you have to check
out we checked out I didn't want to
chance it and they were like we need you
here at this time and it seemed like a
lot of time that they needed us there
but before the actual raping or before
the live event okay but I didn't want
you know it's it's snowing out or
whatever it's cold I don't know the city
and I'm like I don't have far away that
is so we left at the end of the third
quarter oh okay because I would have
thought like you know theythey got they
to start freaking out a lot sooner than
that no it wasn't that bad it was at the
end of the third quarter
so the worst part about it was I was I
was hoping for a blowout just sell like
a forty two point game I love it doesn't
matter but it was the opposite wasn't it
I mean it was it was fantastic and so
many Super Bowls even like the one the
year before John not quite like that
right but and then they turn into it and
you'd miss it and you know so at least
let's put it look at that be you you got
to see three-quarters of yeah good
football action in a Super Bowl and out
the silver lining cuz I would say it
would be far worse for you to have left
thinking oh I got it may this things
like last year right like last year and
then they came back yeah yeah so at
least I got to see good football for
three quarters and actually I got to see
the entire fourth quarter from from the
green room from the green oh she did see
the yeah yeah who was in agreement with
you who else was with you there the
whole show we did yeah it was Chrissy
Mandy Milo sterling I was there everyone
yeah everyone so the whole the whole us
the whole us the them everyone together
and then we had a bunch of like you know
producers there and a bunch of PR people
right he's nice it was kind of like a
party and you hit the NBA slam dunk
right you were at the
I went to the all-star game as well I've
been just hitting all that I'm a huge
sports guy right so I mean I'm like
milking this for everything right and
now you're going to Fontana right yeah
I'm gonna do that I'm a big NASCAR fans
all right I got it
who's your girl Dale's my guy Dale
doesn't race anymore Jimmie Johnson's
always been my guy and then you know
Jeff Gordon is was my first sort of when
I my brother got me into NASCAR several
years ago okay and he was a big Jeff
Gordon guy and so you know I became a
big Jeff Gordon guy and it was a great
time to be a Jeff Gordon fan because he
just won everything and so some Hendrick
guy as well I liked him although like
Austin Dillon is a really nice guy won
the Daytona so they're all really I mean
who I met they've all they're all super
guys now Dale jr. yeah you did a piece
with him right yes eSports yeah for like
his for his retirement sort of like a
saying about so you OC you you gave a
tribute or you said like from a fan's
perspective what do you mean - I mean I
think he's I think he there are certain
athletes that sort of transcend their
sport and they're they also are amazing
ambassadors for the sport and so I think
if you look at and and the family legacy
and the way that he sort of carried it
forward and you know made it it
continues to be relevant so you know I
mean it that that sport for his family
they are they are NASCAR mm-hmm and he's
been able to sort of sort of mold his
own path and carry the carry the torch
and now he's he's doing other things
that are that are sort of beyond NASCAR
he did the Olympics he's amazing
yeah he's got a lot of energy and and um
he's a good guy yeah I mean but I guess
if anybody would know anything about
like lose or skeleton or going would be
hip right going fast going very fast
I've heard there's a way to like do that
did you get that they will put you on
one of those in like like you get like a
driver and you can kind of experience it
what if I like to do
well I mean the thing is like luge at
least your your feet first
sure skeleton you you are headfirst oh
it's just a bad idea just sounds
horrible what's more my speed that's my
next birthday thing by the way I've been
talking to my friends about this we do
like fur so for every year I do like a
thing for my birthday so I try to do
something you know different
yeah and my next one is gonna be curling
we're gonna find a curling club and
we're gonna go curling now you have no
idea what you just walked in to take a
break we'll be back in 67 case that's a
tease for Justin Justin Hartley is here
and you are there 8 4 4 2 O 4 H number 2
Dominic sneaking a phone call as well
before we close up shop but we're back
with Justin Hartley we'll talk this is
us as well
season finale coming up back in 60
seconds Justin Hartley of this is us we
were just chatting about curling he were
more my speed we talked about it on our
show recently we have him we said
there's got to be a spot in Los Angeles
and then there's gotta be there is
really no where it is it's called the
what does it class called the Hollywood
curling club it's an always it's in
Valencia that's weird hey look you know
sometimes the you know you got to go to
the mountain listen I have the
technology to get to Valencia I could do
that so we were thinking cuz we were
gonna do a piece about curling the three
right because you know curling is a four
person operation two three and then for
that guy right you mm-hmm
you want to do it I'll do it I'll bring
a broom think I don't think it's a BYOB
situation
provide one they provide the broom I
think it's not really a broom it's it's
kind of sweet you know what else they
have though what uniforms okay I've been
dying I'm 41 years old I've been dying
to like just why we need to wear a
uniform so you're like it's been years I
need to figure out a reason to worry
it's not a little like your character
right now let's get uniforms guys maybe
we should fashion team rich eyes and
show uniforms and we have to play
somebody don't we Patrick's pretty good
at that though all right I'm just doing
that we are really spitballing we are
spitballing are there other pickup games
I mean just like where we're next
we wrapped two weeks ago so I have a
nothing to do I'm around if anyone wants
to challenge me to curling I think maybe
we all practice swing let's wait you
don't wing stones though usually you
don't wait it's gonna be amazing
we're in that's right Justin Hartley
here on the Rich Eisen show I mean what
has it been like for you with this this
show man it's been great it's it's been
you know we were talking earlier about
Dale and sort of transcending NASCAR and
this show has been first of all it's
it's my dream job I've never had a job
like this not even close and I've had
some really good jobs but I will have
things like what I mean by that is
people will walk up to me that I do not
know and start telling me things about
their life that are intimate you know
details and it's I think it's just it's
cathartic for them obviously and they're
like getting it off their off their
chest and I feel like it's helping and
so that's something that I never thought
in a million years that I would get from
any kind of you know acting job so
that's been kind of so people are what
sharing their battles with alcoholism
with your shoes like that
or it could be anything divorce loss of
a child victories also good so you know
celebratory things okay but it's been
it's been insane I mean it's been insane
in a good way just incredible I can't
even who would have thought that that
would happen where someone would walk up
to you and smile and first of all you
know people say all the time they're
like does it ever get old people walking
up to you and I'm like no because I'm
not a politician right mmm I'm not even
an athlete where it's like I they hate
my team or something like people that
walk up there they're generally very
happy and you know happy to see you
which is nice so it's just like a bunch
of warm fuzzies it's nice it's good I
mean to be able to do something that's
so meaningful to other people there's
clearly a connection if somebody's
coming up to you yeah yeah so
congratulations thanks man I mean a part
of something like that and and the
writing is incredible the writings in
credit so it all starts just like when
you get a script when you get it's like
candy like being a kid in a candy store
you you I flipped through it and I try
to you know you try to absorb it but
you're also like trying to get to the
next page and every script they seem to
outdo themselves I'm not quite sure how
they've been able to do that for such a
long time but I mean we've only been on
two years right but I remember reading
the pilot thinking I have to figure out
a way to get on this to get this job
like there's somehow I have to get this
this role in in particular were you well
my friend my friend called me and he
said do you know Dan Fogelman
Dan Fogelman created the show and I said
yeah and he goes how long have you known
him I said well now I don't know him
we're not friends I don't love him you
know who the man is and he goes I think
he just wrote you and he I go send me
the script so he sends me the script and
I'm reading it and the first the opening
page and I start to see it I'm like oh
yeah Jack cuz he's got the he loves his
wife and he's the loyal guy and that's
awesome like I'm Jack yeah great and
then I kept flipping and I realized oh
no I'm Kevin like I like he's talking
about Kevin that's Who I am right
that's who he sees me as my friend and
so I ended up going in I got lucky
enough to get the audition and it's
actually a pretty easy process it was
not two auditions and then and then the
call well let's put a few more meat on
the bones is it because you you try to
be an athlete and in
is that what I mean whatever what's the
Kevin in you yeah you know gosh I get
him from a different sort of angle I the
way I see him is I think the opposite of
what he is at first glance and I think
at first glance like if you took a
snapshot of him for instance when we
first saw him he's sitting it's his
birthday he's sitting on a bed with
these two models he's got it he's at a
party and what I saw was I didn't see a
guy that was like oh he's got a ton of
friends in a huge house and he's got
models in his bedroom and it's his
birthday and everyone loves him I saw a
guy that probably had his house that
might not be paid for packed full of
people that he probably doesn't know
sitting with two girls that he's never
had a conversation with probably does
that me friends and he's alone
surrounded by people in in this room and
that's so depressing and sad and he's
trying to do everything he can to take
the focus off of that so that no one
will notice who he really is that's what
I saw and that's heartbreaking and I
thought man if we if they're gonna tell
that story and then that's the story
that they ended up telling so you see
this guy go down this path alone he's
he's just alone and misunderstood and
even when he cries out for help and
tries to say my god help me I'm not
worth anything people are just like gosh
so humble so humble right and it's it's
like you're crying for help and no one's
hearing you so Wow
we went down this path on the show and
one of the things that we talked about
was and I'll tell you a good friend of
mine is Ryan Leaf and Ryan's been
phenomenal to me and and and and sharing
his story and we just thought we wanted
to make sure that we got it right and we
told the story that you know when this
stuff happens you know when drug
addiction alcoholism all of that stuff
this mental health issues these are not
things that you get out of on your own
and you've drawn upon Ryan Leaf and he
was generous enough to come in the man
he's a man of all men he came in to our
writers room it's a group of like 15
people that he had never met and he gave
us everything he had Wow
I mean everything and it's right there
it's like when he's telling the story
you're just like it's so it's his it's
his personal story and he's sharing with
strangers and he trusted us enough
it was important enough to him the story
that we were telling to to make sure
that it was done you know the right way
not that he's coming in and saying do it
the right way sure but he but he just
had such a mean impact on that room of
genius writers that I feel I'm so proud
of the story that we told him the way
that we told it I think it was that was
important it's to do like a sort of an
accurate depiction this is us the season
finale again next Tuesday 9:00 Eastern
Time on on NBC and it just ngratulations
on all that
thanks ma'am just to shows you that you
know one minute you could be an actor
flying to New York next to a soon to be
completely failed one and done reality
TV show years later sitting on that
shows that hosts new show that's right
before years in that's right everything
[Laughter]
before I let you go you being one a part
of the big three let's do a start bench
cut let's live with Justin Hartley here
of this is us can you hit start bench
all right you have three choices okay
okay you can start one you can bench one
you can cut one okay okay okay so that's
it this that's it you start one you
bench one here it is sports broadcaster
you would give up your airplane seat
next to Chris Berman Dan Patrick
Rich Eisen this is a tough one I have to
give up my seat next to one of these
guys well no you would give up you would
give up your airplane seat to sit next
to I mean like I'm sitting next to you
now so I have to say you would you bench
and cut would you bench you got a bench
one gosh you guys I can't do that can i
I can't do that I'm not the guy I'm not
the guy for that do I have to answer
that
okay he's too nice I would I'd cut
Berman I'd bench you know you you're
forgiving guy bench you
[Laughter]
asked to go to the bathroom I'll just do
it right there and loved everything
about your career so far and what's
going on with you you're welcome here
any time and what I've never said this
to another person
let's go curly let's go curling let's do
it I'm not kidding Justin Hartley at
Justin Hartley on Twitter when we come
back one more TV only segment with the
Justin and we will compare work out
Instagram videos between one guy here
and another guy crossed the way well it
might del to foe that's coming up Justin
Hartley one more segment with Justin
here and we noticed you have a JJ Watt
like work out likes to put on his social
media of him working out or he just on
like he'll jump on top of like a filing
cabinet right but we have I think we
have some video do you not there we go
there we go dude what are you talking
about jumps on a funny cow you're
jumping Wow that's absurd that's JJ Watt
like yeah that my friends asked me they
were like so did you get rid of the
wires and post or what and I'm like you
jerks that's like a legit just yeah did
you get rid of the wires like a mission
impossible it's not 12 feet is that
Glaser's place by the way it is okay
unbreakable yeah I'll have a lot of fun
there I do that now come on yeah you're
planking with how much weight is that on
I'm sure I think those are 45 one those
are 45 each woo and then some throws
another that's 180 yeah BAM that's one
more give me one more he's gonna do one
more you're at are you asked
it's the Dodger hat extra gives you the
extra that's crazy way that was a queeg
like show getting right there look
could've done more it's not that's crazy
hold on you plank 1:45 oh yeah that's
good as long as you're doing it the
right way as long as you are so nice man
because we're just like race all doubted
you got to get video he's gonna do
though he's gonna do what he's gonna do
one he's gonna do 165 Instagram this is
that was a lot heavier then keep your
arms up it looks right it's exhausting
it is exhausting just where is this
because it looks like you have
atmosphere smoke and NBC called this is
Mike you guys are great
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience